I believe that the challenges we're
facing
globally as a business community and as
a species are getting so large and and
so complex that the way we do business
has to fundamentally change and and the
big pivot is about a deep change in the
priorities of business kind of a flip
from worrying about short-term earnings
first and then getting to some of these
kind of shared challenges we have only
when you know there's pressure from
outsiders or there's maybe quick wins or
kind of easy wins that companies can
pursue and flipping that so that we're
operating businesses in a way that
tackles our biggest challenges and works
back from there and says how do we do
that using the tools of capitalism and
markets and competition to do it most
profitably often what people call
sustainability which is not I think
always the perfect word but but the
things that fall under that that are
environmental or social challenges
there's this assumption and business
quite often that that trying to tackle
these issues will be expensive that
there's this trade-off this fundamental
trade-off between trying to manage these
big challenges in a profitable way and
just managing your bottom line in a
normal way and that that's gonna be
expensive this myth was based in some
reality for a long time there were
things that did cost more money and and
green products or green services they
weren't very good for a long time so
there's a sense that Green was somehow
not good for business it wasn't out of
nowhere but that's really a dated view
we now have a situation where the
challenges are so vast and the world is
changing so fundamentally that the only
path we have forward is to manage these
issues that's the point of the big pivot
so that we will find a profitable path
to do it and we have so many options now
there's a whole category of things that
companies do that save money very
quickly all things that fall under kind
of the banner of eco efficiency or
energy efficiency or using less I mean
in part Green is about doing more with
less that's just good business and so
that part of the agenda has become much
more normal in companies and they're
finding ways to cut costs dramatically
that's the easy stuff but we're now
finding even the things that seemed very
expensive for a while like say going to
renewable energy that's one of the
example
people always use if we're gonna go
green we're gonna put solar on a roof
and it's gonna cost so much the cost of
that has been dropping dramatically 70
80 % reduction in cost of you know using
solar power in the last five years so
the economics have shifted this is now
very good for business almost all of the
agenda of the big pivot is good for
business in the long term in the medium
term and very often in the short term so
there isn't this trade-off this is the
path to growth this is the path to
innovation to building your brand to
cutting costs into cutting risk all the
value drivers that you can create in
business this pivot will help you enable
climate change is arguably and I believe
really the the greatest challenge we
face for Humanity and I'm not alone in
this there's now voices coming to the
table that are from unusual places you
know former US Treasury secretaries you
know have put out a report called risky
business that talks about how expensive
this has become just for the economy and
for all of our cities and how expensive
it will be how dangerous it is
they call it an existential threat I
mean these are these are aggressive
statements and so you're seeing people
starting to create a bigger social
movement because we need that too for a
change this big it isn't just business
or government citizens need to be
involved recently in New York City there
was a very large climate March I took
part with my family and there and me and
400,000 of my closest friends and it got
very little attention in the press
there's a very strange thing that's
happened where I don't know climate
change is boring it's not sexy it
doesn't seem exciting and so it doesn't
get the coverage it needs and and it's
it's kind of shocking because this was
one of the largest public demonstrations
around anything environmental I think
ever and it was one of the larger
marches in New York history and yet it
kind of missed the boat for the press
and I think that's the fault of the
press more than of people I think people
and I find businesses are much more
aware of these issues and are moving on
them then then anybody covering it will
give them credit for and it's a shame I
think there's an opportunity to
highlight how far we've come
and and the opportunities we have to
change our lives for the better and make
business a part of the solution and make
it you know more prosperous and more
profitable and I think we're missing out
on telling that story